des caniches corps car elle qu'elle a
glissé de l'info est de l'intox gérard à
toi de jouer jeudi le groupe o2i petit
chien mais je pense que c'est de l'info
et toi je pense aussi alors toi tu lis
tu m'as dit que c'était de l'info
victoire il chaîne de l'intox c'est
énervant ça c'est pas très indépendants
font preuve depuis le début alors
philippe s de l'info est de l'intox quoi
philippe commun ces deux là font c'est
de l'alcool c'est de l'info d'un
commentaire à faire un commentaire je
peux oui ah oui thierry guidon les
douanes ça dépend bien de charras non
ouais parce que là tu pourrais pas me
laisser finir ma partie a donc je fasse
mon commentaire parce que j'avais
préparé quelque chose de très méchant
sur charasse mais là je suis en train de
battre mon record ou tetris tu veux pas
dans j'en ai pour 3 minutes d'accord
bafilo score 2-1 pour lhermitte